- It could either feel
elegant or like a porn star.
(lively whimsical music)
- I'm not gonna lie to you,
I'm kind of scared of this.
- Is this really what my
fingernail would feel like,
if it was isolated?
- Got my nails lined up.
- And I have to hold it for a bit,
or just ... ?
- [Voiceover] Did you read
the instructions?
- [Young man] No.
- Okay. I glued myself to myself.
- It's one of these
moments where you realize
that, like, "Oh, I use my thumbs a lot."
- Ooh, that one kind of hurts.
It, like, kinda digs into my
skin, but it looks better.
Beauty is pain.
- Oh, it's hard to do stuff already.
It's kind of like a talon.
- I feel a lot less in control
of my hands and my fingers.
- Like, this is what
Gollum would look like
building a model airplane.
- Got it.
- Ooh, I could seduce a
younger man right now.
- Kind of feel like a little
bit like Edward Scissorhands.
A little bit, you know, like maybe I could
go around to bushes and just, like ...
- This is one of those things where,
if life is gonna be much
more difficult with these
than without these, then
I really don't get these.
- Okay. This is hard. I'm trying
to get it out of my pocket.
- Putting these on, I
don't wanna break them.
- Damn! It would be hard
to text your grandson.
- I usually press my buttons like this.
And now I have to go like that.
- I like using, like, my
swipe feature on this.
It's way too hard to use swipe.
And it's even harder to,
like, delete, delete stuff,
because my initial instinct is
to just type it with my nail.
- All right. I'm getting
better, better at it.
But I definitely have to
adjust how I do everything.
- I'll text my mom.
Gonna try and gonna take
a little selfie here.
(camera shutter clicks)
- These nails say, "I
really like to Instagram."
- Let's do a selfie.
(camera shutter clicks)
- Okay, this is, this is just difficult.
- Hashtag -- nope, that's a percentage.
- (bleep) Theory and Google Voice?
That's probably for people that have this.
(camera shutter clicks repeatedly)
(bell rings)
- It definitely makes
you feel a different way,
which is a combination of,
like, dainty and in control.
- I feel like I'd have to go through some,
like, 80s montage training to
figure out how to use these.
- I like the freedom that
my fingertips give me.
- I never go up to a woman and be, like,
"I like your nails!"
- I can't be a big opponent of them.
I kind of dig them. I can
see what it's all about.
- My initial instinct was to say, like,
"Why would you want to
grow your nails out?
"Like, that makes your life
harder, yadda, yadda, yadda."
But at the same time, like,
I don't wanna invalidate what you want.
- Wearing new things, like, obviously
makes you feel a different way.
And that's, like, one of
the most interesting things
I feel like I learned from, like, these,
"try a fashion for the
first time" is, like,
there's a specific way
that something like this
makes you feel, and that's
kinda the fun behind it
and that's kinda the fun
behind fashion in general.
(swoosh, hinge creaks)